you
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Irene I was an intern
with our studio last summer working with
a Thai diverse team specifically with
Jenny Brian with who many of you know
and now I'm based of Tel Aviv and today
I'll be talking about the puzzles I was
the data science puzzles I was building
last summer some of the and some of the
extra concepts that we were trying to
also convey through these puzzles is
that really echoing or no yes okay well
sorry and so this story really starts
over a year ago in December I was
supposed to be writing my thesis or
something instead I was drawn into these
coding challenges online known as the
advent of code and as you might guess
from the name these are a series of
puzzles daily puzzles from December 1st
to the 25th and they cover a lot all
kinds of different computer science
concepts but in really fun ways and just
to get give you a sense of what that
looks like this is just a screenshot
from that page you have some puzzle text
telling you what the problem is you know
there's a robot running up to you and
there's some tragedy that you have to
solve at the very bottom there's a link
to your unique puzzle input so maybe
there's just a lot of garbled text that
you have to somehow parse and then at
the very bottom is a little text box for
you to enter your answer and you know
get your little star and so these
puzzles can be solved in any number of
different programming languages as in
our user I used our and I found that I
was using our and very unfamiliar in
unnatural ways but but I was still able
to solve a lot of the puzzles a little
did I know at the time but Jenny
Brian was also solving these puzzles
around the same time and she took that
feeling one step further she thought
well these puzzles are a lot of fun but
why don't we make a set of puzzles that
highlight what are and the tidy verse
are actually good at in other words how
about we make a set of puzzles that
focus on the idea of messy data and
tidying it up and so that's how this
project was born it's currently known Oh
as the tidies of March it looked better
on my computer
so they've become a series of bite-sized
puzzles that focus on core data science
skills as championed by the tidy River
set of packages I think I forgot to
mention at the beginning there is a
github repo with nicer looking slides
that will be linked to at the at the end
as well and so just before I move on I
wanted to quickly tell you about the
name I think that the phrase beware the
Ides of March is maybe familiar to some
of you it comes from the tragedy of
Julius Caesar by Shakespeare and so you
have this fortune teller coming up to
Caesar saying like beware the Ides of
March which means but where the 15th of
March
Caesars like okay whatever dude and of
course come 15th of March
Caesars assassinated more tragedy ensues
and I think the moral the story is that
you and your data do not have to fall
into the same fate
you can avert tragedy by using the tidy
verse and tidy tools and so for this
project we had a number of different
goals we had some more general goals we
wanted to build up a community around
these puzzles to have a space where
people can share their solutions and see
other people's solutions whether it's in
tidy verse or besar or Python and then
we wanted to be able to create a bank of
solutions of to these discrete data
wrangling problems but beyond that we
also wanted to impart on people some
very specific skills first off we wanted
to help people exercise their wrangling
skills for beginners introducing them to
a lot of these different packages for
more advanced users showing them some of
these lesser-known functions within
these packages and beyond that we also
wanted to promote the concept of
workflow well hello workflow and project
management that's supposed to be a
little [ __ ] icon
and and in order to do that what we did
was rather than just have this web
interface where you can just go off and
use whatever IDE or whatever you know
whatever tool you wanted we were gonna
build an R package that guided you
through that process
and guided guided you through some and
showed you modeled some of these best
practices so that you can start to
internalize some of those things and so
this is more or less what it looks like
like with any other package you start
with a library call you start with an
initialize puzzles function and you pass
it a directory name and what it does is
it creates a new project for you and
then sets you up with a number of
different files we'll just take a quick
look at that here and so first before
before anything else we if you'd use
this are mediated route or this are
mediated experience we force a few
things on you we forced you to use an
art project we think it's a very good
idea to use these projects and keep keep
all the file the relevant files in one
place keep it portable so that you can
access those same files from a different
computer and it will just work and then
and this use this logos in the bottom
corner here because it was a big
inspiration for for this for this
package it focuses a lot on workflows
and on making some of those kind of more
imma take meticulous tasks a little bit
more easy to do you see here there are a
number of other files ooh the dot puzzle
files store some of your user
information you have zero one underscore
putts that's your first puzzle and as
the days go on you can download
additional puzzles as additional folders
and then you have a readme so if you now
put this project on a github repository
you have that already set up for you and
automatically generated and so now if we
click into the puzzle folder we see a
number of things maybe the first thing
you notice is the naming convention you
see that it's every
thing starts with a zero one underscore
we use an underscore rather than a space
we use that leading zero so that once we
have more than ten puzzles it will still
order nicely so basically we're
following and modeling the principles of
having names that are machine readable
human readable and that play well with
default ordering and these files
specifically I think you can see here
you have one file that's the data file
that's the file that you need of
Wrangell in this case it's an excel file
we have a solution script that's been
started for you and I'll show that in a
second and then you have the puzzle text
and so that's that problem that you're
trying to solve like that's you know
Johnny has some problem with his
microwave data and you have to solve it
and so this is what the solution script
looks like there are number of things
that we've kind of put into here you
don't necessarily have to understand it
all but I'll point out a few here first
we have this pre populated path because
of this very rigid structure we know
where everything is we can just populate
that data path and you can choose the
import function you want to use there
are a few other things we use here here
so that we can use the same relative
path both in your our scripts and in
your our markdown files our markdown in
our scripts they understand the home
directory in a slightly different way
and this makes it just work across
different file types this weird notation
here with this hashtag the positive fee
and hashtag Plus that allows you to have
an R script that functions in the same
way as an R markdown file where you can
have text mixed in with your code and
then the last bit that that I point out
here is this options tidy verse quiet
equals truth that just turns off all the
tidy verse attached messages so that
when we had this rendered file we just
have that library call without all those
extra messages and so jumping back to
the rimi this is what it looks like now
that you have a sense of what that
repository looks like here it doesn't
look very impressive it automatically
generates a table of contents which with
a
Ingle puzzle is just like okay but you
can imagine that with 20 puzzles or even
with 5 puzzles having something that
just automatically generates is a saves
you a lot of work and so the idea behind
this is really that we set up a lot of
things for you in advance and when your
project its small is small it feels like
just extra work but yours we're setting
you up to really easily extend and
enlarge that project so when you have a
lot going on when you want to publish
this to github when you want to create a
website out of it a lot of the
architecture is already in place for you
to use and so of course I can't do this
talk without showing you an example of
what a puzzle is and so we'll run
through just this very simple example so
let's say we have a sandwich shop they
make really good sandwiches from BLTs to
fluffer nutters which i did not know was
actually very popular until this week
it's a marshmallow peanutbutter sandwich
but since many of their specialty
ingredients keep going bad they've
decided to focus only on their most
popular sandwich and so to help with the
decision they've collected some data
here it is or here's a sample of it and
you have in the left hand side the names
of their customers on the right hand
side you have the sandwiches
list their favorite sandwiches
semicolons separated in no particular
order and then it says at the bottom in
this sample the Dagwood sandwich is the
most popular in the full data set what
is the most popular sandwich among the
customers so that question in Bowles at
the bottom that's the question that
you're trying to answer in the end and
before we wrangle the data I want to
point out that within that puzzle
question we have a test case we have a
sample the data
the answer to that sample and that way
you can start out by writing a script
that that works for the sample and in
the case of small data sets maybe
doesn't make a big difference but you
can imagine that if you're working with
hundreds of thousands of rows really you
want to test it on something small make
sure it works have a script that works
for most if not all of your
use cases and then move on to that full
data set and the test and test our MD
packages have are good places to go
learn more about testing so this is just
the table output of that same same table
that you saw earlier I've called it SW
in this case sandwiches and the first
thing we want to do here is take those
sandwiches and have just one sandwich
per row instead of this kind of list
within the column here and so the tidy
our function a tidier package has a very
useful function called separate rows you
just take that column sandwiches Tillet
the separator is some I call colon space
and you have everything worked out for
you here you might also want it to pay
attention a little bit
are there some spelling mistakes are
there some inconsistencies in
capitalization in this case we'll just
assume everything is perfect because it
normally is and and now we've just
counted and so we count sandwiches sore
equals true bumps the most popular
sandwich to the top so we have Dagwood
at the top that's exactly what we
expected great we are ready to submit
our solution and so we'll go ahead and
do that so now we go back to our
interface type and submit puzzle Dagwood
the puzzle number was 11 it says give it
another try oh right that was the sample
that wasn't the full data set let's try
again bacon egg and cheese I happen to
know that's the answer
magic and it says correct you are dandy
that's just praise from the praise
package which is very very encouraging
and and in this case it's rendered it as
a rep rekon the side later we actually
change it to our markdown to rendering
it through the our markdown package but
basically but now on the side you have a
way of previewing that solution script
that you had written you can make sure
that the final output is what you expect
and both the our markdown package and
the red X package they
they force you to do certain things
which are actually really good practice
they force you to make sure that you
have all those library calls in place
they force you to make sure that you
actually have everything in order for
definitely for myself when I was
starting with arm and our script was
this interactive thing where I would
like run this part and then this line
and then this line and that that doesn't
really work when you're trying to
reproduce it and use that script six
months later and so both of these
packages really forced you to do certain
things right and so to conclude with
this project we wanted to show off a lot
of things in the tidy verse but really
there was there's a lot more to data
science into the data wrangling than
just the functions in the tidy verse
there's also the idea of using projects
using version control using a solid file
and folder structure with good names
that are possible and predictable using
test cases and using code that is
reproducible and re runnable and with
that thank you my contact information is
there github repo with the slides and
other resources and thank you
[Applause]
so we have some time for questions if
you have a question please raise your
hand and we have some mic throwers yeah
yeah we can start here thanks for the
awesome presentation I was just
wondering if you got to apply the same
thinking to the learner package like
does it fit somewhere into the
experiment you were trying to do I did
look at the learner package at some
point I don't remember exactly what it
does anymore but that is something that
that Jenny has in mind and I don't know
if it will be incorporated or not but
the learner package is for sure a good
way of teaching as well go ahead
oh sorry what's your goal for the
difficulty level of these like for
beginners intermediates I think we're
thinking of like not absolutely fresh
beginner but basically anywhere from
like beginner intermediate to to
advanced also I mean if you're advanced
you can do it as kind of like a speed
challenge if you'd like and I think I
found that for advanced users these
puzzles take between like ten to thirty
minutes and sometimes it's just the luck
of thinking of the right solution and so
really we won't try to cover a really
broad range of levels and we do start
out with easier levels and then kind of
level up to you know JSON files and
things like that other questions
thanks very much this looks great - you
give the suggested solutions at the end
somewhere the reason I'm asking the
separate Rose thing how many times have
I done separate and then gathered
together instead of just using that
one-liner I think well we it hasn't been
fully developed yet I think the idea is
that so in the puzzles themselves I
didn't show the web interface that we
developed but there are little places
for hints and so things like that would
be in the hints where it's like maybe
you want to try this time your function
it's handy sorry we nearly lost elapsed
up there
I was just wondering what sort of
feedback you've got so far from people
so far I've mostly mostly been talking
to our ladies I I didn't I was in Paris
and I did a meet-up there and those the
the group of people I was working with
there were mostly beginner ish and for
them I think it was it was an
interesting exercise for sure it took
longer than I expected and I know
there's some like wording issues
sometimes that comes up but but in
general I think the feedback hasn't been
positive I did some virtual virtual
sessions with some our ladies online as
well and so far we have had positive
feedback but we haven't really put it to
the test yet
[Laughter]
hi I teach at a college and I'm just
wondering like my students don't use our
projects don't yell at me so I'm just
wondering if there would be a way to use
the puzzles without it sort of all the
lovely tools you've built to go along
with it
so there is a web interface it's the
same way the advent of code does which
is totally language agnostic it gives
you the puzzle text the problem you're
trying to solve it gives you a link to
to the file that you have to download
and then other than that you just
there's a text box for you to submit
your final answer and everything in
between
that's up to you you can use whatever
workflow suits you thanks
this is fascinating and it makes me want
to see the puzzles is there a website
where we can actually go and try your
studies of code puzzles you said there
is a web interface yes it is it is a
prototype it's currently a shiny R
markdown that is hosted on our stereo
Kinect so I don't know what the timeline
is unfortunately because I am not in
charge of the project anymore
you can ask Jenny Brian maybe she would
know but I think sometime in the next
year they will be released and you can
try them it is in a private repository
on github but once everything is
released we would like to make it public
right now they're all the puzzles
solutions are also contained in the repo
and the way we were able to separate the
solutions and the and like the user
interface was through an API it gets a
little bit more technical but if you're
interested feel free to talk to me or
read my blog post about that
the song yeah great how do you see this
fitting into a greater kind of God I
lost the word are the puzzles grouped by
any sort of common category or they
simply like them increasing difficulty
like would they fit into a curriculum
somehow okay that is something we were
considering I tried that in the
beginning we were thinking structuring
it kind of week by week having some kind
of theme so originally we're thinking
okay week one we'll work with data
import in all the annoying parts of data
import week two we'll work on something
else
week four we'll be tidy eval we realized
that timeline specifically was maybe a
little bit unrealistic I think I've
dropped that the automatic part of it
but I think it would be cool once we
have these set of puzzles to have other
themed puzzles maybe maybe just a whole
month of Tidy eval for the folks who
really want to do that or a whole month
on you know per some more specific
aspect this is kind of just entry to the
tidy verse style all right
you
[Music]